I mean I I love Nolan like I've
recruited Nolan to Penn State like I I
was his host like don't lose my guy his
sailing is high I think for where he's
gone
like you see that production like what
we're talking about for where he's gone
this is a great pick and production wise
it definitely I think he has a chance to
fly through the roof right being in a
system where it's going to be more
towards him a five-man front
wait Jordan Davis Jalen Carter and
Hassan and Josh and a pleasure Cox I
mean they just got Fletcher Cox Brandy
Graham 2.0 right like they just reloaded
there yeah I mean I mean her future said
I mean how do you feel AJ
I'm loving every bit of this AJ they
can't be able to pay you he does not he
he needs some tissue he needs some
tissue he he he really the show is over
he's ready to go home for the money
no yo see he's trying to take shots at
your pocket right yeah yeah yeah it's
cool you know what he's gonna play he's
paid he got two years left hey you know
what bro two years to win the Super Bowl
this is not about me this is not about
me listening this is about the the
Philadelphia Eagles and and Nolan Smith
that pick along with Daniel Carter yeah
I want to see his footage you don't know
what to say let's see this is Nolan
Smith